good morning we woke up and decided that
we wanted to go see some snow today so
guess what we're doing
we're gonna go see some snow but before
we do that
what is going on no dude there might be
spiders or ants or something in there
he's trying to get bit by once he could
be spiderman no i already said don't
spiders can hurt you so you don't want
to get bit by him all right
um yeah we're gonna go get breakfast
first and then we're gonna hit the snow
out here in vegas i think
where are we going mount charleston or
something mountain charleston
that's where we're going
so
let's let the apartheid started
so today we are checking out the spot
called
world
famous
chicken and waffles we've actually been
here before and we did a get lost
episode hash house the go-go's we got
the big oh is this what this is yeah but
that one was in the casino this is more
out in the suburbs got it so hopefully
the line isn't as crazy got it okay so
this was funny to me
because if you've seen elf
you know the part where he's in new york
and then it says the world's same as
coffee and then he walks into the
restaurant and goes congratulations
i kind of got a glimpse of that because
i saw that sign and i was like world
famous drinking waffles but no it's
house a go-go so never mind i've been
here before do you believe i could jump
all the way up there no what which one
do you think on the head maybe the third
maybe the fourth maybe the fourth okay
what do you think i could jump
you got dolly up there
was it the fourth right this one
i called it the fourth one two three yup
four
damn someone could jump this though
probably
i didn't
record any of our food
i was a little hungry but we're outside
now and we're gonna start heading to the
snow
okay go
whoa
wow miles
nice
whoa
whoa
whoa
whoa
oh yeah
oh no
nice
ready
i feel like something's gonna break
nah
i was gonna jump i know what you're
gonna do
get out of here move back to l.a
we are now off to our adventure tomorrow
mount charleston
we're about an hour away
which
i think is perfect timing yep because
because uh this guy hasn't caught some
z's yet and in the restaurant he was
getting a little bit grumpy which is
usually z time so i think he's going to
be able to take along z i don't want to
say the word and jinx it and then when
we get to the destination he'll go
wow
and be fresh yeah
huh
so taika just discovered how gum works
let me see you chew gum
and it's the cutest ever
i actually gave him some gum because he
has um a cough still and like he keeps
humming because i guess it soothes his
throat so instead of coughing he'll go
because it'll like massage or tickle the
inside of his throat
so i gave him this um
shout outs to project seven
it's all like locale uh organic uh low
sugar candy and gum so i gave him a
a peppermint gum
to kind of help soothe this throw and
open up his little his little nostrils a
little bit so you can breathe
and it's been working he hasn't coughed
so
look at how gorgeous all of this is
look at that peak right there wow it
looks like the clouds are like steaming
off the mountain right
either that or i'm imagining a lot of
snow
just coming down like this yeah like
half of it is cloud and the other half
is snow like right in that area
yeah it's beautiful it looks foggy
because bart's um
mirror is pretty dusty
but it's also looking pretty dusty over
there
like that
baby that's just what marriage is about
i don't think you've read the marriage
license but that's what it says
oh really dude
look at this beauty
wow
wow holy crap
[ __ ]
so tyka is still sleeping
papa had to pull over
to get a picture of this beauty look at
that holy crap oh thank you clouds look
at that
so you can get some really good lighting
in there but holy crap that's gorgeous
wow
just your picture
yeah it's getting real getting a good
one nice
and just like that
winter wonderland look at this
gorgeousness
this is
such a beautiful [ __ ] look at these
trees dude
i know if you don't haven't been born
and raised in california you're like
yeah what is this this is nothing but
for my california peeps look at this
ugh
it's disgusting how beautiful this is
look at this look at it
wow
wow
wow
good morning
you just woke up
what do you see
snow everywhere huh what do you see
yeah you ready to go in the snow
all right
let's get ready let's get you warm and
put your jacket on so you don't freeze
go back down
okay duty are you ready yes
wow you look warm but my dress is so
good
hey
good job wait look at all the snowfall
don't throw it at me
you look so warm are you warm
you're one duty
wow look how soft this is look
whoa
nice soft snow
monkey take a look
it's not that cold wow you're so warm
you got something on your neck too good
job
whoa that's a big one
that's a big one don't throw it out the
cars okay
you can throw it over here
wow
wow
you're a climber
you're a climber duty
[Applause]
why are you gonna go all the way up
there
you did such a good job with dressing
him he looks so yeah he's wearing one of
these things so there's no snow getting
in anywhere
yeah
good job judy
[Music]
good job
[Applause]
all right guys so
this is the snow resort
in las vegas lee canyon and we're here
so if you guys ever want to check it out
they got a ski lift that goes all the
way up there and wow you can see the
clouds moving i was about to see that
that's
yeah so if you want to ski snowboard you
can do everything here
pretty freaking cool because i never
would have thought in a million years
and i think vegas
i always think casino hotels right i
don't really think of all the other cool
nature stuff but there's actually a ton
as you guys have seen with red rock
canyon and all that
and
there's a big old snow resort here with
real snow
and because you know it actually snows
here it's not like the snow machines so
if you're looking for some powder you
might get some i don't know if there's a
snowboard park i didn't see any like
jibs or anything like that but
if you want to bomb down some mountains
look at that fresh snow
waiting for you
let's go
this guy loves the snow so much
he didn't want to come i know you didn't
want to come
it's the best look at this and we found
a really cool place a nice little cute
bridge over there all these beautiful
trees oh look at the clouds
damn
it's a beaut and i found a cool little
parking spot
thank goodness for four-wheel drive
you're sticking out yeah my truck looks
sick over here
damn dog
i need to take a picture of this hold on
a second
good job
cuny guy this guy couldn't wait
so a super nice cop just came up and
told me over the megaphone and they're
like excuse me sir are you the owner of
that sick ass white pickup truck i'm
like if we're talking about the sick ass
one that's mine if it's about a regular
one that's not mine he goes yeah sir the
sick ass one i'm like thank you he says
well can you please drive past that line
because whenever your little butt butt
sticking out like that it might get in
the way of ambulances and stuff and i
was like dude
that's freaking cool thank you for
talking to me so nice i'm gonna move it
right now and so far
i love the police out here they're
so friendly and i never get the chance i
never get the feeling we can go we're
gonna do what we can do
for some reason in l.a i always feel
like i already did something wrong and i
don't feel like they're the public
servant like they're gonna serve me but
out here it feels like they're really
trying to protect everything and they're
not gonna make sense in la2 they're just
so little cops to so many people we have
a ton of criminals yes we know okay true
yeah and then there's people that get
that pull people over and when they pull
them over the guy already has a gun
facing out the door
we hear some horror stories like a lot
of buddies that are cops in la and so
when the cops
are pulling passengers over they're as
scared as the people getting pulled over
because
that could be the last time they pull
someone over you know so but out here
love it so far love the way that guy
talked to me in a i'm a mover right now
so i told papa he was gonna get stuck
and guess what he is stuck
now what do you do huh
i can't wait to be like told you
what did i say
i said you're gonna get stuck
and what happened
can you get out uh can you do me a favor
no i just need you to sit in the back
put some weight on it or you drive us in
the back
okay
all right so like always should have
listened to mama but now i'm sitting in
the back of the truck mama's gonna drive
hopefully this additional weight will
help it move
who knows
but we'll see
now not at all
all right
planned that's plan b
plan c
i need to stick the uh
the boogie board
underneath i'm gonna go get the boogie
board okay yeah and then stick it hey
close the door duty
close the door
all right
that's plan
c
hopefully that catches
gets enough grip
and it can back out
we'll see if we could do it
are you driving or me driving you
i drive yeah i don't i don't know how
this thing works because as soon as i
turned it on and put it in reverse the
wheels just started spinning like crazy
okay yeah can you uh record it from the
outside there see if it works
all right let's see if this works wait
there's like three cars coming okay
like really slowly
hold on
[Music]
all right you're clear
all right hopefully
go
nope nope nope nothing nothing nothing
hold on
no i think it's too slippery
all right let's try that
oh oh oh it's happening
nothing it just kicked it forward
nothing
way to go dude
all right so now now that's it
yeah come on
so papa flag down
a nice samaritan it's gonna help andy
and tech are just playing
display duty
[Music]
why try it it's just snow
it's too deep it's not deep
i'm right here look i'm standing
no it's not try it just jump it's soft
jump
jump it's soft trust me
go
go
don't be scared it's just snow baby
nothing to happen i'm gonna go around no
do it trust me look i already stepped in
it step in my foot
where i stepped and you step
go
see it's soft oh but it's looking to die
huh
[Applause]
yeah let's go
okay let's do a big big ball okay push
you kind of push me okay wait you got to
put this on so you don't get it all on
your back
okay ready boom
is that too hard
no that was a lot okay
sorry
okay let's make a snowman
that might don't kick it okay that might
be a
rock okay let's make the big base
can you stand on this edge so the camera
can watch us
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you can see we're back in the
truck and we are in motion which
means we got unstuck how did that happen
the unstuck because i know how that
stuck happened
so how did this stuck happen let's talk
about that so
i didn't think i was gonna get stuck
because it's snow which compacts and
melts and does all that stuff and i got
pretty big tires compared to my last
truck but i drove in and uh i got stuck
and then the guy that came over he
seemed like a super wilderness guy
because he has shovels max tracks which
are those traction pad things and a
winch and you pretty much told me like
when you're going deep snow
when you compress the snow now the snow
is compressed and uh my truck was
sitting on it so my tires were dangling
it wasn't touching the ground
and so this guy was nice enough to pull
over in the first place he had a winch
um he hooked me up and at first when he
was pulling
the the car wouldn't move his car wasn't
moved because his car was too light
so his tires would spin and he would
just stay stuck so we came out and he
was nice and i think his wife or his
girlfriend or whatever we all were just
digging the snow
out behind the tires and out underneath
the car so it helped get more traction
we put those max tracks things in and
slowly were able to pull out and what
was cool was in the middle of it another
truck pulled up and he was like hey you
guys need help they were just so awesome
and so friendly and uh yeah his max
tracks were these plastic things they've
been hit being hit by the sun for a long
time
so uh my tires just shredded them up
into pieces and i felt so bad i'm like
hey man you got venmo or zelda or
something i'll send you some money for
you guys don't worry about it dude and
he was like that's what these things are
for anyways i'm like yeah for you
they're here to save your life not save
mine
and then i i i
realized i had some cash on him i mean i
mean so i gave him a hundred bucks he
was like oh man thank you so much he's
like merry christmas and at that moment
it was so cool because i was like
dude that's like those movie moments you
know like someone gets stuck or
something bad happens but then there's
always that christmas miracle that
happens and it's like merry christmas i
was like merry christmas to you too so
we're able to get unstuck and i was able
to play with tycoon right after
so why didn't you listen to your wife
let's talk about that
yeah
i'm just kidding i know i know you just
want to have a good time i'm just
pulling your leg it's not a big deal but
um it was just pretty funny that i
called it i'm like but this is gonna
happen this is gonna happen and then i
was right i was hoping i was gonna be
right but
it is what it is um you had the
confidence of like well we're not all
alone out here someone will help us
yeah i mean just driving on the way up i
saw so many uh nevada hp
i've seen uh so many of the forest
rangers
so many like off-road rigs out here i
was like i'm good so they just gave me
the super confidence to you know like if
you're a surfing and there's like 12
life guards like i'm gonna go a little
bit crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
no it was fun it makes for good memories
for sure it's just some other like it's
just
more bragging i can do you know what i
mean so that's what i'm grateful for i
have like these these memories i can
keep in my pocket so when like you try
to like talk [ __ ] to me i'm like oh
really and i'm going to pull this on be
like what about that time and you're
going to be like [ __ ] which is right you
never win you know why
because ultimately i go oh you know what
got me stuck i didn't have a winch on my
truck i have to get one now
and so you know when you go no you don't
need a winch and i don't remember that
one time i got stuck
i think quenches are cool
this is like the third time or fourth
time you've gotten
stuck pretty bad
yeah
i think you should get one i think
they're pretty cool they are pretty cool
but what i realized i was working with
that guy you got to maintain them this
was kind of rusty the glass not working
oh that is one of those things where
it's like it is like more yeah right
more maintenance right so i just got to
listen to my wife ultimately and not get
myself in sketchy situations this feels
weird i don't like it don't do that
don't say no i know but when you're nice
i like the banter
that's what i love tough love you know
so when you're being nice and now you're
agreeing with me it's weird i don't like
it where's the off-road trailer i want
to go on it no see back to the mattress
like that
we're back home and miles morales is
back at it again
whoa
careful oh my god don't do that anymore
what do you have so our neighbors are
super nice
and they got us something for christmas
are you ready
yeah let's see
okay close your eyes close your eyes i
want to see his facial expression i
don't know we can't see what the
freaking miles morales mask off okay
take it off take off the hoodie so you
can see you can see it ready it should
hit your face your eyes open no okay
close them they are closed okay open
them
oh
my god
all right wait i want to be nosy what do
we have we got oh
yes
i think a cinnamon one i would say this
is peppermint chocolate chip and a big
chocolate peppermint ooh monkey which
one are you gonna eat this one i knew it
don't touch it jesus
oh
oh really
says the guy with the are you gonna eat
that
the owl i have a spiderweb
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
whoa
dinner time and i found this fun place
and it's the first time i've ever seen
this so i'm really excited to try it but
their house special pho
is uh the rare steak plus a bunch of
seafood
hey look at this
what i've never seen this before you got
meatballs shrimp crab and then extra
meat
gotta try the broth i'm gonna boil it up
give it a fair chance hopefully it's
really really really really really good
um that's one thing that i haven't found
one as good as la slash oc it is a dank
asphalt
so i've tried maybe like four or five
places some places come pretty close but
still not like a golden deli or like a
nah train you know i mean so
what you can eat for dinner
whoa like ricochet uh i'm actually
eating a meal
they're about to start you're trying to
get skinny already you should get lean
already no i'm not trying to do any of
that i just like the flavor of it cuny
it is really good i love bison monster
mash i love you talk about monster
measure all the time but shout out to
standard yeah we love it i'm not trying
to be on the diet i just have such a
simple pellet are you gonna eat like
four of them oh no i just got cold okay
oh my god i know
all right so this is promising
because a lot of the fun places i've
been out here the broth isn't like um
really deep like that and usually when
you get that rich rich fu flavor
you need that deep color
and that one
looked dank
does that look pink
[Applause]
all right look how freaking hooked up
this thing looks doesn't even fit in the
bowl probably if i got at the restaurant
it might have been a way bigger bowl but
now i got to do the dank test
see if it came out good or not i hope
it's the day i know you're looking for
i hope it i hope i hope
it's pretty good nothing still not laoc
dang but
oh you know what i should then should
have made it boiling boiling i didn't
realize that the noodles were cold
so it brought the temp down should have
boiled boiled it but still good
okay monkey what are we doing right now
we're trying to put we're trying to make
sure to eat
the cookies i was about to send him off
to bed he was wait we have to leave
santa some cookies
okay so let's leave sent a cookie yeah
and then he needs milk yucca
yeah that cookie looks yummy hey you
can't be touching are you gonna give
santa covered dude
can't we touch the cook with your
fingers
okay let's see from a little bit of milk
yeah
that's it mama oh that's him yeah he's
probably so full he can't give him that
much milk okay and we also have to give
his reindeer something right does
rangers have to eat something what do
you want what should the reindeers eat
not even this a big cabbage
oh how about this they love celery
i'll give them some celery oh yeah
okay where do we leave it oh let's leave
it but let's put the the here you bring
the celery take the bet we'll take the
the rubber band off come on let's
right
[Music]
okay do you want to leave santa a note
what um yeah what are you gonna tell him
i don't know you say thank you for
bringing me my presents um
he's gonna leave why
cause you have to call home
oh you want to leave them a note saying
thank you
no oh okay
all right is that it yeah okay all right
then uh now go to bed everyone good
night
yeah
all right so we just put the duty to bed
which means now it's parent hour
we got pop over there uh who's gonna
start wrapping some of tyga's presents i
got some over here
it's time to get to work i hope you guys
have a wonderful holiday
um whatever it is that you celebrate or
don't celebrate i just want to send you
all the love in the world thank you so
much